sí
caramba nadie más de corazón que cada
cuerpo
viví tres años conectado una máquina que
me ayudaba a respirar adentro de casa
podía mover mi solo 12 metros porque eso
era lo que media la manguerita que me
conectaba con el equipo para salir usaba
un tubo de oxígeno que al principio de
la enfermedad me duraba 8 horas
tal vez parece poco pero se podían hacer
un montón de cosas en ese tiempo el tema
es que al final como yo iba demandando
cada vez más oxígeno del tubo apenas
duraba una hora y media si tiene una
enfermedad muy rara y poco frecuente que
no tiene cura ni tratamiento la única
solución en un trasplante bipulmonar
cuando me dijeron que necesitan un
trasplante sentí que el futuro había
desaparecido que no ya quedó sin tiempo
y supe que a partir de ese momento las
cosas no iban a ser sencillas porque la
enfermedad era degenerativa se activa
empeorando siempre
pero a pesar de todo eso quise encontrar
algo positivo y me di cuenta que podía
mostrarle a mi hija que es posible
transitar una universidad con alegría y
buen humor y la verdad que eso lo cambió
todo porque lo que era un problema
tremendo hasta ese momento de gol pero
vi como una oportunidad había logrado
encontrarle un sentido a las cosas que
me pasaron
me propuse hacer lo mejor que podía con
las cosas que venían fui adaptando me a
las limitaciones y nunca hay que hacer
las cosas que me gustan si empresas qué
fotos y a medida que la enfermedad
avanza va empiece a sacar fotos de cosas
chiquitas porque voy a hacerlo en casa
sin moverme demasiado
tenía unos muñequitos articulados de las
guerras las galaxias y me divertí
haciéndolos interactuar con las cosas
cotidianas que tenía en casa
la foto en sí nunca fue en fin siempre
era una excusa para disfrutar el proceso
lúdico de hacerla tiene una excusa para
jugar
yo soy diseñador gráfico y creo que algo
de eso en la foto se nota
me acuerdo cuando estudiaba en una clase
de diseño nos pidieron que dibujemos una
botella
terminamos dibujar y colgamos todos los
trabajos en la pared
el profesor los miro dibuja un círculo
en el pizarrón y nos dijo que eso era su
botella
no teníamos demasiado y después nos
aclaró que era una botella vista desde
abajo
y fue muy loco porque había más de 40
botellas dibujadas todas distintas pero
todas hechas desde el mismo punto de
vista como si nos hubiésemos puesto de
acuerdo era raro
pareciera que tenemos imágenes ya
establecidas de las cosas y nos cuesta
verlas desde otro lado
las fotos me hacen acordar ese ejercicio
porque el objeto no cambia siempre el
mismo lo que cambia es la manera en que
nosotros lo vemos y una foto esa
diferencia la botella y se cambió hace
resignificar el objeto nuestra cosa le
cambia el sentido
paralelamente a todo esto que era
divertido la enfermedad avanzaba súper
rápido
o sea cualquier tarea cotidiana y la
complicada
me acuerdo que después de ducharme y ya
no podía secarlo con la toalla porque
era un esfuerzo que no podía hacer me di
cuenta que podía sacarme el cuerpo con
el secador de pelo
el tema es que al poco tiempo también me
descompensaba a sostener el secador
tanto tiempo
ya lo último anime secado después de la
ducha me sentaba y esperaba sacar mi sol
en esa instancia ya la enfermedad medio
ha quitado muchas cosas pero no la
posibilidad de elegir y decidí seguir
disfrutando de las cosas aunque fueran
muy difíciles de hacer porque sabía que
normalmente van a ser imposibles y de
hecho así fue quedó internado en terapia
intensiva esperando que llegue el órgano
la situación ahí ya era bastante crítica
pero a pesar de esto eso yo estaba
contento porque sentía que había logrado
lo que me había propuesto había sido muy
feliz durante todo el proceso
después de pocas semanas llegaron los
pulmones que hoy me hacen hablar sin
estar pendiente de la respiración
siempre me sentí un privilegiado si a
partir de ese día muchísimo más todos
los días agradezco y también me esfuerzo
todos los días en ser merecedor de ese
regalo
cuando pasó la tormenta y repase todo lo
que había vivido me di cuenta de tres
cosas la primera es que a pesar de haber
estado lista de espera yo jamás esperé
vivía disfrutando cada presente y
enfocado en las cosas lindas que tenía
la segunda es que tanto la felicidad
como el sufrimiento son decisiones
propias
y la tercera es que a pesar que eso no
podía hacer nada para cambiar la
realidad verla de otra manera me hizo
transitar la enfermedad de otra manera
al cambiar el punto de vista tenemos la
posibilidad de resignificar las cosas y
así como la máscara oxígeno que usaba yo
puede convertirse en una nave espacial
del mismo modo un problema puede
convertirse en cualquier otra cosa y eso
está buenísimo porque por un lado nos
pone en un lugar activo nosotros
elegimos desde dónde mirar pero por otro
lado nos hace responsables porque más
allá de las cosas que nos pasen lo
importante es lo que nosotros hacemos
con eso
gracias
[Música]
sólo se le da